first tonight with just 27 days until
election day
you are the ultimate jury something
pretty remarkable
happened for the very first time since
being tapped by joe biden to serve as
his running mate
kamala harris tonight was forced to
answer serious questions about her track
record
her past comments and yes her
frightening socialist agenda
and thanks to the corrupt media mob
which is all in on team biden
senator harris has never been asked to
seriously address
any controversial issue like for example
the time that senator harris said that
she believed
the sexual misconduct allegations
against joe biden or the time that she
accused joe biden of
coddling the reputation of
segregationists those questions still
need to be asked or the time that
shaw book called joe biden a racist on a
primary debate stage and said she
wouldn't be a senator if the people he
praised had had their way
or the time that in fact it came up
often she co-sponsored the radical green
new deal in the senate or the time she
wanted to ban red meat plastic straws
ban oil gas and yes she said it
joe has said it many times will prove in
a minute fracking
or the time by the way she called for
gun confiscation via
executive order if congress didn't act
the way she wanted
and let's not forget the time that she
publicly supported court packing
by the way she again tonight refused to
answer that question
i don't think that's going to go over
well or the time that she smeared judge
kavanaugh that was brought up tonight
and tried to ruin his life
or the time that she supported medicare
for all or the time that she
supported taxpayer-funded health care
for illegal immigrants or the time that
she
compared law enforcement to the klu klux
klan in other words ice agents
or the time that she supported a bail
fund that got rioters and
even accused child rapists out of jail
like she did in minnesota
or the time she praised los angeles for
slashing the police
budget in other words defunding the
police senator harris
has never been held accountable for any
of this and with just
27 days to go we got our first insight
into all these questions she has never
answered that was until vice president
mike pence
he took matters into his own hands and
the vice president started by holding
the biden harris campaign responsible
for plagiarizing what was the
president's plan in response to covet
19.
watch this the reality is when you look
at the biden plan it reads an awful lot
like what president trump and i and our
task force have been doing every step
of the way and quite frankly
when i look at their plan that talks
about advancing testing
creating new ppe developing a vaccine
it looks a little bit like plagiarism
which is something joe biden knows a
little bit about
and as you can see it was pretty obvious
all throughout the evening the entire 90
minutes senator harris was
very uncomfortable when confronted with
the truth at times she could do a little
more than
make these awkward smiles and just shake
her head and
and clearly she blatantly lied over and
over again
let's start with her lie tonight about
taxes watch this
him take he says he's smart because he
can take advantage of the tax
code and he does take advantage of the
tax code that's why
i'm going to eliminate the trump tax
cuts and we're gonna we're gonna
eliminate those taxes
the truth and the fact is joe biden has
been very clear
he will not raise taxes on anybody who
makes less than four hundred thousand
dollars appeal the trump tax cut mr vice
president i'm speaking
i'm speaking be important if you said
the truth
joe biden said twice in the debate last
week that he's going to repeal the trump
tax cuts
that was tax cuts that gave the average
working family
two thousand dollars in a tax break
every single year
senator that is absolutely
i guess the media mob will try and
protect both joe biden
and kamala harris but she was caught
outright lying to her teeth about the
issue of fracking and we've got all the
video evidence take a look
i am not banning frackie let me say that
again
i am not banning frackie no more no no
fracking
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal
and fracking in the biden administration
no we would we would work it out we
would make sure it's eliminated and no
more subsidies for either one of those
so first of all i will repeat and the
american people know
that joe biden will not ban fracking
that is a
fact will you commit to implementing a
federal
ban on fracking your first day in office
adding the united states to the list of
countries who have banned this
devastating practice
there's no question i'm in favor of
banning fracking so yeah
i'm in favor of banning fracking joe
biden i'll eliminate fracking
they said it now both joe biden and
kamala harris on record denying their
own words
and by the way following those remarks
ocasio-cortez
well she sent a very stern reminder to
kamala harris on twitter writing
fracking is bad actually and meanwhile
when senator harris was finally forced
to answer for biden's cozy relationship
with china
harris tried to dodge that question take
a look at this
joe he i think he said it quite well he
says you know
foreign policy it might sound
complicated but really it's
relationships
so just think about it as relationships
and
so we know this in our personal and
professional relationships um
you got to keep your word to your
friends god be loyal to your friends
people who've stood with you
got to stand with them you got to know
who your adversaries
are and keep them in check now the vice
president was nicer than i would have
been because we know
that joe is loyal to his friends you
know
like the people in ukraine where zero
experience hunter made millions of
dollars
or china where zero experienced hunter
got a 1.5 billion dollar deal with the
bank of china
i guess that's loyalty of friends now
why on earth would senator harris or joe
biden
ever have anything negative to say about
china after all joe biden has been
sucking up to china for decades
and that's likely the reason that zero
experience hunter
has been lining his pockets with
sweetheart deals connected to the
communist party of china for years
and shopping sprees thanks to china
nationals chinese nationals
or ukrainian oligarchs or russian
oligarchs as we've only recently learned
and according to that u.s senate report
that was put out by charles grassley and
senator johnson hunter biden actually
opened a joint bank account
with the chinese national guess why to
fund a hundred thousand dollar
shopping spree for members of hunter's
family he also reportedly scored
lucrative multi-million dollar business
deals with
foreign nationals associated with
china's communist party
and also china's military and during the
obama administration
state department officials they were
openly worried that
hunter's problematic activities and
business dealings create
serious counter intelligence and
extortion concerns
maybe i don't know i'm just guessing
maybe that's why for
the first part of let's see through
january the end of january when the
president put the travel ban in effect
10 days after the first identified case
of corona
in america joe biden called it
xenophobic and hysterical
and also fear-mongering why maybe he
wanted more deals for hunter
but tonight by far the most
cringe-worthy disturbing moment of the
debate
came when kamala harris did everything
she could do not to answer
whether or not she or joe biden support
packing the u.s supreme court
something that hasn't happened in over
150 years we've always had
nine members on the court well
apparently there's a reason they won't
answer take a look at this
thank you senator harrison susan are
voting right now they'd like to know if
you and joe biden are going to
pack the supreme court if you don't get
your way in this nomination
let's talk about that you once again
gave a non-answer joe biden gave it
anonymous trying to answer your american
people deserve a straight answer
and if you haven't figured it out yet
the straight answer is they are going to
pack the supreme court
if they somehow win this election this
is beyond a serious topic why because we
have co-equal branches of government we
have checks and balances
and whether or not all three co-equal
branches of government will survive a
potential
biden harris administration and senator
harris thinks that she can just punt
well that's pretty unconscionable what
would that mean
that would mean well radical justices on
the u.s supreme court and what
perpetuity
they're going to put 11 on the court 13
on the court how about go for a nice
even 18.
that would be pretty repulsive because
what people can't get done legislatively
or can't get done at the ballot box by
convincing the american people
they would hope activist justices do
from the supreme court
the american people deserve an answer
and given by the way her dodgy remarks
you better believe
that that certainly is on the table and
by the way just like getting rid of the
legislative filibuster
and pushing for statehood for puerto
rico and d.c if they get elected
more questions they need to answer
because if elected
that would mean a democratic majority in
the u.s senate probably in perpetuity
that means this would be the most
radical destructive administration
in american history and they don't want
to 27 days outside of an election
be honest and forthright and transparent
with the american people
if you do care about constitutional
order if you care about
co-equal branches of government if you
care about checks and balances
if you care about something called the
bill of rights your freedoms your
pursuit of happiness
well vote like a country depends on it
because apparently it does in 27 days